it was June 2014 I was 30 years old and
I received a call from my doctor's
office to say my test results were in so
I walked up to see her in my lunch break
and my doctor said she was very sorry to
tell me that I had breast cancer I
didn't want to believe her and at first
I didn't you see I'm a lawyer and I
needed some evidence so I'm very
embarrassed to tell you all that I stood
up and I walked around to where she was
sitting so that I could look over her
shoulder and verify what was written on
the page in front of her malignant
carcinoma but still not wanting to
believe it I said now
malignant carcinoma you're sure that
means cancer she told me she was sure
back at work I handed over the urgent
things that needed to be done while I
was having more tests to save my cancer
had spread but at that moment work
wasn't my priority I was thinking about
how I was going to tell my family and
friends that I had cancer how I was
going to answer their questions about
how bad it was and whether I was going
to be okay
when I didn't know that myself I was
wondering if my partner and I would ever
have an opportunity to start a family
and I was figuring out how I was going
to tell my mother who had herself had
breast cancer when she was pregnant with
me she would know how I was feeling and
have an idea of what lay ahead for me
but I also didn't want her to have to
relive her cancer experience what I
didn't appreciate at the time was that
work was about to play a huge role in my
treatment and recovery that it would be
my co-workers and my job that would make
me feel valuable inhuman at times when I
would have otherwise felt like a
statistic that it would be my job that
would give me a routine and stability
when
dealing with so many difficult personal
decisions and so much uncertainty like
what sort of breast reconstruction I was
going to have and at a time like that
you would think that I would turn to my
family and friends for support and yes
of course I did that but it would
ultimately be my colleagues who would
play a huge role in my day-to-day life
and they would be the ones to make me
laugh you see we were a pretty close
team and we showed a couple of really
good in jokes like this time they
overheard someone ask me how I got my
hair so shiny and perfect without
knowing that it was of course a wig and
you know it was a very good wig and it
did make getting ready in the mornings
very easy but in little moments like
this I appreciated what their support
meant and I wondered what I would have
done without that Network
I've spoken with so many people women in
particular who haven't had the chance to
have that network because they haven't
been given the opportunity to work
through treatment and there are several
reasons for this but I think it mostly
comes down to overly paternalistic
employers these employers want you to go
away and focus on yourself and come back
when you're better and they use those
kinds of phrases and while these
responses are well-meaning
knowing the benefits that brought me it
makes me incredibly frustrated when
people are told that they couldn't or
shouldn't work when it's something that
they want to do and physically can do so
I started to look into what an employer
is required to do when someone presents
with a cancer diagnosis I discover that
under Australian law cancer is
considered a disability so if you are
unable to perform your usual work duties
your employer is obligated by the
Disability Discrimination Act to make
reasonable adjustments to your working
arrangements so that you can
continue to work what would reasonable
adjustments look like for me I knew that
obvious impacts my diagnosis was going
to have on work medical appointments
would be scheduled during business hours
and I knew that I would need time off to
recover from surgical procedures again
being a typical lawyer I had done my due
diligence on what to expect from
treatment admittedly a lot of that was
through dr. Google perhaps not my best
move and I wouldn't recommend that but
while I was ready for all of the
physical side effects what really scared
me
was this thing called chemo brain chemo
brain presents itself through memory
loss and inability to concentrate and an
inability to solve problems and if this
happened to me I wondered how I was
going to do my job as a lawyer would I
be forced to leave work and how could I
possibly have a discussion with my
manager about reasonable adjustments to
my working arrangements but I didn't
know how I was going to be impacted I
was fortunate to have a supportive
manager who was happy to see how things
went as we went along
rather than requiring a concrete plan
upfront I was lucky that while he may
not have even known about this concept
of reasonable adjustments to him it was
just common sense but I've learned that
it's not common sense to everyone
everyone going through treatment will
learn how it impacts them and what their
limitations are and they'll learn to
adjust for that so for me there were the
tips and tricks that I learnt about the
treatment itself like before you go to
chemo you need to make sure you're
really well hydrated and that you're
warm because it helps the nurses to find
your veins and make sure that you don't
eat any of your favorite food either
before or after chemo because you're
going to be throwing that up and you
won't ever want to look at it again I
learnt that one the hard way and then
there were the tricks for managing my
workflow I scheduled chemo for first
thing
Monday morning I knew that from the time
I left the cancer care unit I had about
four hours before this fog screen would
come down and I would start to be sick
so I would use that time to clear my
inbox and make an urgent calls the worst
of the sickness would be gone within
about 48 hours and then I would log back
in to work from home as treatment
continued and I knew what to expect I
was able to set reasonable expectations
with my business partners about what I
could do and the timeframes that I could
do it in but I still remember the
hesitation in their voices when it came
to asking for things and asking me to do
things by a certain time and trust me
these were people that were not afraid
of setting a good deadline I got the
impression they didn't want to put any
extra pressure on me while I was going
through treatment and while I
appreciated the sentiment actually
needed the deadlines to me that was
something within my control and
something that could stay in my control
when there were so many things that
couldn't and as I was working from home
I was thinking about how employers
should be applying this concept of
reasonable adjustments in our current
age where one in two Australian men and
women will be diagnosed with cancer by
the age of 85 so as we continue to work
longer and longer into older age the
chances of having a serious illness
while we're in the workforce
is increasing and with technology
enabling us to work anywhere any time
reasonable adjustments are no longer
contingent upon whether or not you can
continue to physically make it into the
physical office reasonable adjustments
are also not about just offering a
longer break or a comfy a chair to sit
in
although those things might be good too
at the very least we need to be applying
the flexibility policies and strategies
we've developed for other scenarios like
for people with family responsibilities
but
how can we ensure that people are even
having a conversation about what
reasonable adjustments might look like
for them if a managers first response is
to say oh no don't come back to work
until you're better and the light went
on for me
it must be compulsory for managers to
have to have these conversations with
their employees and lessons from people
like me that have really benefitted from
working through treatment need to be
more widely shared and I thought about
what could be done to guide these
conversations and then an amazing
colleague of mine
Camilla Gunn developed a working with
cancer toolkit the toolkit provides a
framework for those diagnosed their
managers their carers and their
co-workers to have conversations about
cancer and the work support available
Camilla and I have now been to other
organizations to talk about the toolkit
and how it can help to guide through
what quite frankly are otherwise some
pretty awkward conversations and I'm
pleased to say that the uptake of the
toolkit is increasing so what should be
a manager's first response when somebody
says that they're sick and they don't
know how it's going to impact their work
and must be this to the extent that you
are able and want to we would love to
work out an arrangement for you to
continue to work through treatment we
need to start positively engaging people
with serious illness to keep them in the
workforce rather than paternalistically
pushing them away I've told you my story
because I want you to know the benefits
that working through treatment brought
me and I also want to change your
perceptions if you think that somebody
going through treatment is just bored
frail and vomiting a lot and yes these
things were true some of the times if
not a lot of the time but I was also
determined to push myself at work as
much as I had all has done and I was
able to do that because my employer gave
me the choice most importantly I'm
telling you because while it
a seemingly obvious choice to give
someone it's not one that is always
offered or encouraged and it must be
thank you
[Applause]